welcome to this video snow kit snow kit
and yeah I don't think this this guy has
got the name in there nope just a GM
with a Turkish flag wow what a bad score
one and a half out of six I have against
him okay let's play the the stone wall
here via the triangle that's not really
a great line but it's it's pretty
resilient not easy to break down let's
see what we get is played with the
bishop to d6 not with Bishop to e7 very
often here black has to find some
solution for his his Bishop problem and
the bishop on d7 our ad sorry on c8 that
can go to be seven at at at any moment
I'm just going to prepare before him
playing it in a very simple fashion okay
that's quite unusual but ok maybe may
hello maybe I should have prevented the
trade but it's nothing that is in any
way great for black but could have
thought about that trying to prevent the
the nitrate okay I'm going to push this
and i will put the knight on d5 for a
really nice position
now I also have this play on the e-file
so III yeah well at the moment he cannot
play g5 anyway g5 f3 and the night does
not have a retreat square just as it is
the now it has to retreat square okay so
he just blundered the night and hopes to
get some compensation for it let's see
how to do it I have to check the piece
of course okay okay Bishop c4 I can also
put the night there but this looks okay
yeah let's let's keep ups default f4
cupboard queener to does a good job
yeah question should i take it or not
taking it is probably the simplest also
because this hangs yeah rook to h6 maybe
this is a DM on look aged six though I
can consider to even take on your form I
know it's really just a piece
yeah we're thinking queen for would be
three this kind of thing or is there
something then something easier yeah
maybe offer this Bishop trade
the night is really good hanif idea not
just the piece that also it's a
fantastically strong piece on e5 um
maybe look everyone and trying to
threaten rook takes e4 black resign yeah
I just he just blundered the piece it
happens to all of us here he only had
one retreat square for the night and he
just blocked it I mean the position um
is really good for white but of course
he does not need to to lose that quickly
it is good for wide because well I have
the better Bishop here and he's got the
week porn on his six and he has no real
attacking chances I mean who are not
sure what you should do well g5 is not
working here just just wins the house
and I don't know Brooke g8 maybe to try
to prepare that i still play this tea i
can take check winning the queen it's am
not easy at all maybe yes to remove the
Queen dumb yeah I'm not sure I can play
a three I don't need to i also have b5
this is an additional idea be fibers of
course allowing him to get rid of this
bishop but if we consider this anyhow
this is just really bad yeah b7 some bad
porn weakness rupee six is attacking g6
it's a very bad position I mean okay
blundering a piece is not helping him
but he was in some trouble anyway this
line here is simply not good for black
getting the Stonewall set up when wide
still as Bishop f4 three okay thanks for
watching